tiens parce qu'on va faire là on va vous
faire pour mieux vous connaître
on va faire une interview première fois
pour mes premiers souvenirs
la première scène avec mon travail m
ouais ouais
premier choc la première c'est
maintenant travail premier mensonge
la première scène arrête de vous faire
chier maintenant premier amour ôter
toute l'équipe
ah bon ouais ouais ça tombe sous le coup
de la loi
voilà c'est le premier rhum c'est quand
un bisou avec la langue ça s'est réglé
par les bisous avec la langue si je m'en
vais de la bouche bien bien première
idole whitmill stade ah oui oui premier
disque moi je savais qu'ils s'étaient
sénat des jours avec je peux pas avoir
prétendu vraiment avoir travaillé avec
un deuxième disque avec avec passi et
d'ailleurs que sur l'album sur la balle
qu'elle premier vrai grand amour
si c'est pas encore arrivé dit le soyons
honnêtes nombreux téléspectateurs qui
sont intéressés qui se sont pas pas
l'idée de le savoir
non je crois way saison première cuite
avec notre dame
d'ailleurs c'était la seule et l'unique
1 parce que tu m'as dégoûtée ouais ouais
et ses débours mieux réussies par
quasimodo les gares ou des gares ou à
gauche à droite je me souviens pas et
puis puis j'ai une vision paisible bois
un petit peu et il donne un peu de
ricard et puis et un et deux et puis le
troisième
et là j'ai fini dans les toilettes pour
venir raconter pas parce qu'il ya un
ministre de la république
ce discret premier pétard non jamais ah
bon ça m'a jamais lui-même et pas sur
l'une premier succès donc notre dame de
paris
les premiers échecs non l'amitié avec
hélène cigare alors ça va être une belle
histoire c'est moi vous n'êtes pas un
peu ça raconte quoi j'aurais pu devenir
un mythe
bon maintenant se dépêche